ん
鉄球それは鉄製の魂
様々な道具もしくは道具の一部として使用されており大きさはさまざまである
かつて youtube では鉄球を鮮度に熱する現象がとてもブームし数々の鉄球が
線分列せられあ医療の鉄球が
焼とした悲しい歴史があるそんな鉄球を彼はどう扱うのだろうか
うんっ
ポッ
こんにちははじめ社長です見えますか皆さん鉄球の中から失礼していますよ
湯気でこちら鉄球ですもう本当に重くて硬いんですよ僕の経験長を定休ですごいな重く
て硬くていいか金属だから食べるとかそういう考えには至らないと思うんですよ
映画もしもし突然人間が鉄球を食べ
始めたらしてはどんな反応するんでしょうか私こちらを見つけてしまいました
うんすごい
スピーカー&ドア4シルバー金がこれ何かと言いますと骨がスプレー式食用
銀粉スプレーするだけで華やかな純金筆をこれ食べれるスプレーですよで食べ物にこれ
をかけると銀色の食べ物になることが基本的に着替える動いてるだけで今回これを使っ
てこの哲兄そっくり
の食べれる敵機をつくって直前後輩の前で食べてみたらどういう反応するのか試したい
と思いますもう比較的な現象ですからね食べてはいけない穴をこのサイズ分口にパクっ
てん丸呑みしたら
aa でなると思うんですよの言葉つしないしする人もいないしでも彼にしている自分
がいるわけですがどーっとトンどどうどええええ
どうなるか本当にわからないと思うその反応を見ていきたいと思いますなかなかこれと
同じサイズの風を見つけるの難しかったねまあねカーショップから買ってきました
たこ焼きスナックそこから主よ
google となし7分リージェントとリフっていうチョコでここらへん結構
まるかったからでも下達的にいけると思うんだよね子役ちょっと小さい
ってマシュマロ意外と近いかもしれんって練習
作っけど形が若干いびつですねビリヤードすぐ小さいなぁこんな感じですねさ的には
たぶんこれが一番いい気がするんですよ
結局から生じてみましょうかでは早速塗ってみましょうだからここが一番気になる
ところではどうなるんだろ色が食べられるかなって味ってあんの方がきます
あった
大丈夫そうだ
染まりやす的なのがあるんかなと思います
前にかければ前にかけて一番見た目に近い八尾対応します
大谷
ええもうなくなっちゃったウソー階席でしたか冷たいんでもこんなに少ないんが無難か
病んだよからシャリッにかかってるんですけど
これだとちょっとこいつら染まりキラー説があるんですけどなるべく染めてみます
めっちゃ気を入れるんだけどようん
つきみれてるこわー
ばいばい弾切れだ似ても似つきませんね
多分現代の科学ではこれが限界なんでしょこれ以上の議員は食べれません本だけ床に
散らばってたらさ何かうまくとくっつきそうな気もするよね
うーん
無理だねあぜが気になるんですと1回食べてみますいただきます
me
んえっ
なんでもないんですけど体にカイマナそうですか
まあやましまろもたぶんないですね
行けるとしたら甘いカーフシュークリーム4
ん
car
これ以上の議員をたぶん無理なんですけど q てがある意味をリーダーみたいなって
います
あれほどでいきましょうパッと見アルミホイルに見えるんですよ羽富かなりある意味を
得るために近いんで今からターゲットのいると運ってもう持つもとしてアルミホイルで
も作るんですけど
てアルミホイルを作ってる間に突然パクリックった時のリアクションを見てみます
4やアルミホイル魂はもう血球と同速なんで果たしてある意味それとも来たとき人は
どのような感じませんだか見てから
いいいいいいいん
[音楽]
アルミホイルで a
アマチュアの応援よね
流行りましたよねめっちゃんこうんでいいんですよ
[音楽]
ぜひ何度も作るん
ああああああ
すごいですねー
時代はアルミホイールよ
絶対やる笑った猫の心笑ってるねひろがばっかりや強くじゃんしろよしよう
しますよ作りなするって言っている国
平成元年くれたと思う
[音楽]
別の寒いチャーの若い時はした牛がいい
全部んです
あっはぁんっ
[音楽]
いいし
つかなってきましたね
あなたん
ん
[音楽]
実際の中でお腹すいてるからってあれこれなんか目じゃないですよ風が肉
ダメですよシェイクは
てください
うってくれはったずさある番場カー o n やってやる前だろあ2無理みたい
何があ
[音楽]
何が無邪剣くっいや結構いや牽制
ます
うぇい a
ありがちなん
ブーブー
ん
ピザくださいうんうんございましたはい
やばいってそれは13マジで等倍食うん
なあ出した方がいいよねぇ
ある日よあやえこず家でないプッってブラックなってもらおうと思っちゃう
えっね
ねえねえそれねえええええええっ日記 homare n 4ねもうカーンん
なんであるドッキリじゃないわー
[音楽]
me
teame
うううう
me
re だった
なる甘い食った者今あの3クレームに
g の術カフェ